I always loved our conversations with
ESPN MLB insider senior MLB insider Jeff
Passan how are you Jeff hello I am
hanging in there sir I'm hanging in
there this seems particularly it seems
you know two weeks ago sounded ugly then
last time we chatted last week it was
okay everybody's quiet so I'll take that
as good news and now people aren't quiet
anymore
and it's this seems particularly ugly
Jeff it sounds very ugly
yeah it's ugly I'm still don't think
we're at the point now where where we
need to full-on panic to me I think the
full-on panic comes well first we have
to wait and see what the Union says
exactly in its proposal back to to MLB
we understand that they are going to
outright reject the the economics
proposal that MLB gave them on Tuesday
by essentially not acknowledging it our
friend Scott Van Pelt said it's
essentially like if you have a million
dollar home and someone gives you a
$200,000 offer on it you're just not
going to acknowledge that that offer
ever existed and I think the players
aren't going to acknowledge that the
economic proposal from baseball ever
existed so III think after that what
we're gonna get to see is a what do the
players want and B how do the owners
react and that is going to be the
biggest tell of all rich because if the
owners you know if the owners say you
know what we can't talk with these
people we're not going to do this it's
going to be gridlock for a little while
and in the idea of coming back with
spring training on June 10th and an
opening day by the 4th of July is simply
it's not going to happen so I think that
is what's at stake right now well let's
take a piece by piece then Jeff I mean I
mean June 10th seems very pie-in-the-sky
let's just let's just take it one piece
of time
has there been agreement at least on the
safety protocols or that's still
something that's out there that's just
taken aback just makes no sense to
talk about a know like in stone
agreement at this point but there's
there's not going to be an issue there
okay everyone well I've been telling you
this for a while now everyone wants the
same thing with safety like everyone
wants players to be healthy and for
coronavirus not to infiltrate club
houses and to do everything they can to
ensure that doesn't happen and I think
that players while inconvenienced by
this are not ultimately going to put up
much of a protest they you know they
want there they want hot tubs and cold
tubs for example and they should because
that's part of their that's part of
their recovery regimen and when you're
you know going from zero to sixty and
and trying to restart games as quickly
as they are there's no there's the
possibility of injuries and you want to
make sure that your body is as well
tuned as it possibly can be under the
circumstances so I mean there's given
tears taking all that sort of stuff and
as long as everybody's safe and happy I
get that
so like ever let's place it aside so
this is just basically a money issue
right and so like listen yes players say
we're concerned about our health and
safety and they are I don't think that
that's disingenuous but the problem is
they're also concerned about the money
and the money is the thing that they
don't have an agreement on at this point
the health and safety like if you told
baseball players that we are going to
wipe away all of the money issues that
you have and all we need to play
tomorrow is the health and safety
agreement they would get it done in 24
hours truly believe that on the other
hand to do that with with money if you
can take a lot longer than 28 24 hours
well because it certainly if it sounds
like you know the position is
owners saying you know I know we agreed
to the pro rating back in March but the
boots on the ground that the virus has
placed on all of us changes everything
now that we know there's definitely
going to be no fans now that we know the
circumstances under which we will have
to play
pro-grade games we didn't factor that in
in march or we we didn't agree to things
back in March knowing what we'd have to
do here Mary here's the thing the league
the league does believe that it factored
that in the league believes that there's
language in that contract in that deal
with the Players Association that
absolutely covers the scenario that you
just mentioned and and there are words
in there about economic feasibility and
good faith bargaining and that
essentially baseball believes the way
that the contract is worded and I've
talked with a number of lawyers who
agree with the league on this that the
way that it's worded it essentially puts
the onus on the players to bargaining
good faith over what salaries all right
doesn't say specifically over what
salaries are going to be but it says
over the economic feasibility and you
can take economic feasibility and and
extrapolate it out to salaries
considering those are going to be the
the largest taker of capital from owners
so now that we're now though okay so but
now now that we're in a good now that
we're in a good old-fashioned lawyer
taking a look at contract conversation
what if the players believe that the
owners aren't dealing in good faith
because of what max Scherzer's clearly
saying that that this is another pay cut
they're being asked to do and the way
that the owners are putting it out there
by saying that there's not everything is
public information in that baseball's
economic strategy would change if
everything was under the light of day
you know the reading in between the
lines there's a lot of threats about
union busting and using public opinion
in a bad faith way right am I reading
that correctly yes I I don't I'll tell
you I don't I don't I personally have
not gotten the vibe of union busting
from this okay go ahead MLB I think that
MLB just made a kind of a repulsive
offer
okay that's just that's just what it was
I think I if you want to say that's not
bargaining in good faith you know
there's a there's a there's a reasonable
case for that to be made but I also
think that that offer shows MLB believes
that it is operating from a position of
strength because otherwise it would not
offer something that it knows outright
is going to be rejected by the players
and it's going to probably insult the
players and in that position of strength
I don't know what it is exactly because
the the people who are running this
negotiation are professional negotiators
and are much smarter than I am but I
think they have I think they have the
the backing of owners right now who want
to be hardline about this you know these
are people who are not used to losing
money and there's a chance that they're
either not going to make as much theirs
it's clear they're not going to make as
much they have in the past but if you
take MLB at face value they you know
they say that owners are going to be
losing tens in some cases hundreds of
millions of dollars and the problem that
the Players Association has is that it
just doesn't believe that and this is
something rich that goes back it's
endemic I mean it is built into the DNA
of the Major League Baseball Players
Association for the players to come up
and be told and taught do not trust
Major League Baseball
do not trust major league baseball I
mean I don't know if the words are
exactly said like that but that's
essentially the message that's delivered
to every player who comes up in the big
leagues and so when you get to
situations like this where MLB is saying
trust us players are going we want to
see some documents we want to see how
much money you guys are making with your
local television contracts we want to
see how much money you're making in
national television contracts we want to
see what your projections are if you
play no games we want to see all of
these things you know local sponsorship
and stuff like that we want you to
provide
evidence that you are going to be as
poor as you say you are because we can't
take you at your word after all the
things that you've done both
historically and in recent years all
right so then Jeff Passan of ESPN here
on the Rich Eisen show senior MLB
insider are we essentially right now
getting a full on collective bargaining
agreement argument like front-loading
the CBA conversation is that what's
happening right now because if that's
attending right now then we got a
problem because you when you're talking
about when you're when you're saying
words like open the books that just
sounds like 2011 and NFL labor dispute
to me right now that's I just got I just
got a flashbac man that way to me
because again it sounds like it sounds
like I'm being alarmist and you're
telling me not to be that's what this
somehow I don't think I I don't think
you're being alarmist at all i think i
think the alarm bells are are close to
sounding i think that baseball is
further away now from playing then it
was before this week this week this week
has not helped and and maybe we look
back rich in in the things that happened
tuesday and the reaction of the players
wednesday was was necessary for getting
past this impasse that we seem to be
stuck in right now but it may just be
the start of something that takes
baseball down a path of destruction
that's that's what this is like that you
know again i have said this from the
start man and I I just have trouble even
when I see something or hear something
that says like screams to me this is bad
Jeff I get back to the idea that if
baseball doesn't play this year and in
the NBA and NHL and NFL do both the
players and the owners have dug their
own grave so then how much that that's
as simple as I know so then what
what is is that at least in the minds
eye of everybody is there talking at
least it they anywhere think so you know
I think I think what we have here is a
group of men who in some cases inherited
but in a lot of cases made billions of
dollars and did so through shrewd
business decisions and are not likely to
be trifled with when it comes to their
money and and losing lots of it
potentially and I think we have a
players association that feels
emboldened that feels for the most part
together and that feels insulted by the
by what happened on Tuesday with that
the economic proposal from MLB and man
if if you want to unify a group of mid
20s late 20s early 30s mid 30s like very
high testosterone men who have pride in
what they do and why you know it just
it's the wrong group of guys to insult I
don't know maybe there's not a right
group of guys to insult but this group
in particular insulting them is not
going to make them cower it's not going
to push them away from their goal and
their objective it's going to embolden
them and they feel emboldened right now
because they feel like not only are they
in the right economically they feel like
they're on the right morally - and and
while they understand that the general
public looks at players who want to get
what they're supposed to get and who
want to get what the market will bear
for them is greedy which has never made
any sense to me because yeah everybody
else would like everyone else trying to
get theirs I mean that's it's just a
it's just the reality of the world that
for some reason the the general public
sides with owner over labor and I I
don't I don't get that Jeff Passan
you're on the Rich Eisen show a couple
more minutes left with you what
The Trevor Bauer beef with Scott Boras
what's what's that all about
give me the skinny on that I if I if I
had more information I certainly would
tell you Trevor uh Trevor Trevor likes
besom with people like that's just his
thing man if he if he feels a particular
way he will talk about it and and I will
say this Scott Boras Scott Boras has a
lot of influence over the Union right
now he's got the ear of people at the
MLBPA he's got half of the executive
Subcommittee as his clients and and the
executive subcommittee is the group of
eight players who make the biggest
decisions and who were on the calls with
MLB and you know Max Scherzer client of
Scott Boras is he just like the he has
consolidated a great amount of power in
this situation and is not afraid to
wield it and he is one of the hardliners
he is one of the people who believes
that the the agreement from March is
valid for the players that they should
push for their full pro-rata and and
that they need to stick to it and you
know whatever you want to think about
Scott Boras and it's fine
well one thing that you must think about
him
he's a good negotiator generally yeah
like that is that that is what that is
one area of his you can disagree with
him you know morally ethically you can
think he's the devil did a pretty good
negotiator throughout his career and
Gerrit Cole has 324 million reasons say
that and Anthony Rendon and Stephen
Strasburg you have 245 million reasons
and he can go on and on I mean the guy
booked a billion dollars in contracts
this offseason so he is when he's in the
room doing something right and also I
learned in the conversation to have them
last week he can fill out a prescription
no idea is a you get a degree in pharma
pharmacology from the University of
Mississippi
I don't ever call him dr. Boris because
he might get a bigger head than he Artie
gosh so Trevor Bauer is basically
hearing sure's are in these
conversations and assuming it's Boris is
that should we I know you don't want to
wade into these waters I guess but I'm
like I think that is a fair connection
okay so make but I just I don't know
what cause Trevor to say that I I do
know that there's a there's a not
insignificant group of people who
believe that Boris wields too much power
and too much influence but now we're
just getting into politics and palace
entry and the sort of stuff that is as
much and and quite often hearsay as
anything okay so we've got a little less
brass tacks it again this is a this is I
feel like I go through therapy with you
every single time you're you're on here
so let's brass tacks it here it's May 20
what is it 28th May 28th June 10th seems
pie in the sky certainly if player if
baseball players are saying we'll give
you a hundred ten games I mean they you
got to start yesterday if you if you
don't want to play and you know
bone-chilling November like what the
World Series game is snowed out you know
unless of course we just go into a
bubble community right you know what I
mean like I don't know like so you will
percentage-wise it for me what do you
think what do we got here and when if at
all for the whole enchilada yes I'm
still I'm still over 50% I was at I was
at 75 yesterday afternoon or so and and
part of that is because I thought I
thought the union was gonna was going to
bend a little bit I did I did not
believe that the union was going to come
out as strident as it did and when that
happened that definitely decreased the
possibility of the season happening this
year but it certainly did not nullify it
what it did was set up
naeryeo in which the Doomsday trigger
could be pulled it's gonna come down to
the owners I mean I I do believe when
the players say we want to play
I do actually believe that I think there
are some owners who don't really or some
owners who work I think there are some
owners who worry that playing is going
to cost them too much they're going to
lose too much money and that they would
rather just punt the twenty20 season and
that is uh you know that's the scary
thing to hear because it feels like
you're focusing just on 2020 and not the
repercussions beyond damn straight
because you know to use the 94 mid-90s
analogy Sosa and McGwire is not walking
through that door Cal Ripken jr.
breaking Lou Gehrig's streak II prior to
that it's not walking through that door
that's not gonna be a single kumbaya
moment or season that could appear out
of nowhere right like they got back in
the 90s to get everybody back in the
fold you never I mean you never you
never know when a when a ragtag group of
people with a kid coming out of prison
who throws really hard and California
penal league guy in centerfield to
really fast and steals a lot of bases in
an aging third base you're going Indians
ami I know you go Major League on me I
know that is the Clevelander in me I
like to and let the Indians winnings out
the Cubs winning it's not the Red Sox
winning and you're right something like
that does not just materialize the rest
of it but we also didn't predicted Sosa
and McGwire we couldn't predict that
could predicted Cal right I I just think
that the what happened in 1994 should
exist as a history lesson and that
everybody I mean everybody involved in
this process better understand
and what the consequences would be and
and and and here's the thing
like I I genuinely think that this is
going to show who cares about the game
of baseball and who cares about the
bottom line and it'll be interesting to
see what the answer to that question is
well III don't know if this is just you
know the bottom line it here to use that
phrase I don't know why baseball is that
seems to be the only league where that
those are those have to be pitted
against one another you know again I I
don't know what is going on with the NBA
and the NHL and obviously the NFL has a
few weeks and months to have to deal
with something like this but why is it
always baseball where it comes down to
well it's either for the good of the
game who loves the game and who loves
the dollar right why is it always
baseball what the hell I guess I think
hit I think history is a really
difficult thing to ignore and I think
history can be weaponized and I think
that's what's happening I think that if
you had people who wanted to make a deal
they would not they would not always
fall back on on the terrible relations
and and so any seeds of discord but you
know what rich those seeds of discord
that had been sowed in the players and
they were the same ones that were so
generations ago one players fought for
free agency when the notion a free
agency was utterly ridiculous and and
nobody ever thought that thing like that
should happen
I guess I'm I guess the lesson is that
it took so long for Marvin Miller to
finally get his due and of all the years
for that to happen right it's kind of
crazy and and here's here's the thing
though like like the fight for free
agency was a very righteous fight what
what's the union I what I want what I
want players to answer and what I'm
curious about is what's the union
fighting for now if they're if the
answer is they're fighting
for their fair wage and what they
believe they are due and and owed I get
it I totally understand that but but I'm
also curious if it's something more and
and if they they see this as a microcosm
of a bigger thing well and I guess just
I guess again to put it in in full full
bloom here that you know players have
never fought for their wage where where
the threat of maybe winding up on a
ventilator is a possibility right and
also baseball owners have never thought
about the bottom line because a pandemic
is hit either I guess although I don't
know what the conversation was back in
night you know back in the you know back
in 1918 but I guess just and to put a
much lighter note on it as you attempted
to do moments ago if this does not
happen I'll need a lot of Joe booze rum
how does that sound
doesn't happen I'm really looking
forward to covering major-league darts
I'm with you Jeff I'm with you thanks
for the call man you are the best at
what you do I really mean it thanks
again thanks for taking about that's
Jeff Passan he's always so kind enough
to jump on the phone I'm sure he's
pulled in many different directions hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here